Hello I’m ethically-sourced Andrew Heaton
and you’re sustainably watching Mostly Weekly.
Put down the tide pod.
Congratulations, we survived the Government
Shutdown!
this is our 19th shutdown since 1976.
when we hit 20 we get a free coffee!
But brace yourself for another government
shutdown.
And another.
Congress avoided a shutdown this time due
to the revolutionary technology of,
and I’m not making this up… a “talking
stick.”
Apparently Congress couldn’t talk about
immigration policy without a talking stick
to determine who can talk.
Which is juvenile and I think we can all agree
that in 20-
Excuse me I have the talking stick, Sarah,
please, please would you please, thank you.
Thank you.
Congress stopped the shutdown this time by
passing what’s called a “Continuing Resolution”
which just means that government funding continues
as-is until Congress actually passes a budget.
Continuing Resolutions work, but not well.
They don’t account for reallocating funding
if the value of programs has shifted,
or if they can be retired.
And sadly, the last time we went an entire
year without resorting to a CR was 1997.
We’ve been running on Continuing Resolutions
since October,
and, presumably, we will be running on them
up until the Winfrey administration takes over.
Now it's true, many libertarians
view the federal government as one big Human
Resources Department with guns.
And I can understand why you might think a
shutdown
would be cause for libertarians to celebrate.
But you’d be wrong.
Yes, The government is bloated and inefficient,
and we should amputate several of its appendages.
But a government shutdown doesn’t actually
accomplish anything.
It doesn’t shrink the size of federal agencies,
it doesn’t save money;
it’s even counterproductive to limited government
in the long term.
Let me explain.
No shrinkage.
As soon as the federal government reboots:
all the government agencies, drug wars, and
bureaucrats are still there.
In fact a lot of them never left.
Here are some government functions that are
unaffected by shutdowns:
Expense.
Nor do we save any money during a government
shutdown.
Social Security, entitlements, and defense
spending
don’t get their funding cut or reformed.
Plus, like something out of the Twilight Zone,
government shutdowns actually costs America
more
than if the government had just stayed active.
Portrait of a country where government costs
more to shut down than to actually run,
where non-essential employees get paid in
the future for past inactivity.
A country within… the Twilight zone.
And shutdowns are expensive.
According to Standard & Poor, the US economy
lost $24 billion dollars
during the two weeks of the 2013 government
shutdown
that's $1.5 billion per day.
How?
Shutdowns cause mass inefficiencies
that take a heavy economic toll on the private
sector.
The shutdown delays business transactions
requiring federal permits,
it postpones court cases, and restricts travel
by withholding passports.
Plus museums and parks can’t collect fees
which takes revenue from the agencies, and
hurts tourism.
In 2013 about 40% of non-military federal
employees were considered non essential
and they were furloughed, which is a way to
say, temporarily laid off.
But as soon as these forlorn furloughed federal
employees come back, they get backpaid.
In other words, a government shutdown
is basically a mandated, paid vacation for
federal employees.
So the government winds up spending the same
amount than it would have if it stayed open,
but without providing the services our tax
dollars are paying for.
That means veterans may not get their checks,
unemployment benefits stop,
tax rebates cease, and vacations to our finest
national monuments get scuttled.
Backlash
A government shutdown may even hurt the cause
of small government in the long-run.
When societies lose faith in their institutions
they tend to embrace authoritarianism.
When the government doesn’t work, people
tend to respond by seeking,
you guessed it, more government.
It’s like trying to drink yourself sober,
or dealing with playground bullies by giving
one of the bullies a chainsaw.
It would be great if we shrunk the government.
But the government we have should be lean
and efficient, helpful and simple.
Sort of like-
A talking stick.
The way towards limited government is through
debate and legislation,
and giving people and markets time to adjust.
Shutdowns are the opposite of that
they’re a combination partisan, squabbling
and incompetency,
hash tag parti-squab-petency.
The only way past perpetual shutdowns
is if our elected leaders act like civil adults
trying to solve a common problem.
Bipartisanship--